hay expectativa aquí en down in Street
por supuesto en todo el país por conocer
Cuáles serán esos detalles los primeros
lineamientos que entregué el istras en
su primer discurso aquí en las afueras
de Downey Street en un par de horas
sobre Cómo enfrentar la crisis de la
economía en el costo de vida y los
crecientes precios de la energía que
azotan a todo el país está en su primera
alocución luego de que regrese de
balmoral en Escocia donde oficialmente
se ha convertido en la nueva primera
ministra la número 56 en la historia del
país la cuarta desde el referendo del
brexit la tercera mujer en la historia y
es además la 15 la número 15 de los 70
años de el reinado de Isabel segunda la
Reina Isabel la monarca que la jefe de
estado le ha pedido a listras que forme
Un gobierno en su nombre Entonces ha
iniciado oficialmente este en este país
no hay traspaso ni posesión Así que les
traza ha iniciado funciones
inmediatamente y lo que se espera además
esta tarde es que se inician a conocer
Cuáles serán los nombres de los
principales funcionarios de su gabinete
Y por supuesto ese discurso que además
de dar detalles sobre cómo aliviar el
costo de vida y los precios de la
energía también hable sobre seguir
apoyando política y económicamente a
Ucrania en esta invasión de Rusia los
compromisos en el medio ambiente y cómo
posiblemente mejorar la relación con la
Unión Europea por el protocolo de
Irlanda del Norte